OF IT.
THAT'S THE ANKLE.
JOURNEYMAN OUT REACTION, NYPD
SERGEANT AND PRESIDENT OF
NEW YORK CITY'S SERGEANT'S
BENEVOLENT ASSOCIATION AND
MARK FUHRMAN, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER L.A.P.D.
DETECTIVE.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON TONIGHT.
YOU HEARD THE ANGLE.
YOU HAVE SPOKEN WITH POLICE IN
THE PRECINCT WHO HAVE DIRECT
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT'S GOING ON.
NOW, WHAT WAS GOING THROUGH THE
OFFICERS' HEADS WHEN THIS WAS
ALL HAPPENING?
>> HELLO.
>> Laura: GO AHEAD.
I'M SAYING WHAT WAS GOING
THROUGH THEIR HEADS?
>> WAS GOING TO THEIR HEADS,
WITHOUT A POLICE COMMISSIONER
SEVERAL YEARS AGO SEND
OFFICERS TO ENFORCE MINOR CRIMEA
OFFICERS TO ENFORCE MINOR CRIMEO
OFFICERS TO ENFORCE MINOR CRIMET
CIGARETTES.
TWO AND A HALF YEARS AGO WE HAD
A SERGEANT INVOLVED IN A
SHOOTING.
SHOT AT A 66-YEAR-OLD WOMAN WHO
SWUNG AT HIS HEAD WITH A
BASEBALL BAT.
THE COMMISSIONER CONDEMNED IT.
WE'VE SEEN THE COMMISSIONER DID
NOT GET ANY SUPPORT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT.
THE OFFICERS THAT ARE OUT THERE
ON PATROL, OFFICERS HAVING THE
WATER THROWN ON THEM ARE
INDECISIVE IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO AND DO THEY HAVE THE
BACKING OF THE NYPD.
GOING TO MAKE AN ARREST IN THIS
-- ANY INDIVIDUALS SELLING CRACK
TO THEIR HEAD, WE HEAR THE MEDIA
AND OTHER PEOPLE IN THE PUBLIC
SAYING IT'S MINOR CRIMES AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN EVERYTHING WOULD
TURN AGAINST THESE OFFICERS.
THERE'S NO LEADERSHIP IN THE
NYPD.
THIS HAS BEEN A PROBLEM.
WE'VE HAD THREE COPS
ASSASSINATED, SEVERAL COPS
KILLED, NUMEROUS COPS SHOT.
THERE'S NO LEADERSHIP IN THE
NYPD.
AND NONE COMING FROM CITY HALL.
I AM ASKING THE POLICE
COMMISSIONER O'NEILL WITH
EMPATHY IN MY HEART, YOU'VE LOST
THE CONFIDENCE OF THE NYPD
MEMBERS AND TO PLEASE RESIGN.
IN THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC SAFETY
IN THE INTEREST OF --
>> Laura: IT CAN'T CONTINUE.
>> IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO MOVE ON.
>> Laura: THIS CANNOT
CONTINUE.
>> I AM ASKING MAYOR de BLASIO
TO MAKE ONE GOOD DECISION IN
YOUR MAYORAL TERM AND REMOVE THE
POLICE COMMISSIONER.
>> Laura: WILL THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> HE'S LOST THE CONFIDENCE OF
THE NYPD.
>> Laura: LET'S GO TO
MARK FUHRMAN.
I WOULDN'T HOLD MY BREATH ABOUT
de BLASIO DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
IF ANYTHING, YOU WILL CONDEMN
THE POLICE FOR NOT GIVING THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LAUGHING A SOFT
DRINK OR SOMETHING.
I DON'T KNOW.
HE'S NOT DOING ANYTHING.
MARK, YOU TAKE ISSUE WITH THE
FACT THAT AT THE MOMENT, AT THAT
TIME, THE POLICE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING.
AREN'T THEY DAMNED IF THEY AND
DAMNED IF THEY DON'T.
>> IF YOU FEEL THAT WAY, YOU
NEED A NEW JOB.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A TIME WHEN
POLITICIANS OR CHIEFS OR
CAPTAINS OR EVEN LIEUTENANTS ARE
GOING TO BE AT A SCENE AND
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH WHAT
ACTUALLY NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THEY USUALLY HESITATE.
THE PERFECT EXAMPLE IS ANY
DEMONSTRATION.
WE WATCH IN PORTLAND.
WE WATCH IT IN NEW YORK.
WE WATCH IN LOS ANGELES.
TIMES ARE CHANGING BECAUSE THEY
ARE HESITATING TO ENGAGE.
THESE TWO OFFICERS LOOKED
RIDICULOUS IN WHAT THEY DID.
AS SOON AS THEY WERE ASSAULTED,
THEY HAVE THE SUSPECT IN THE
CAR.
THEY SHOULD HAVE PUT OUT AN
ASSISTANCE CALL.
THEY SHOULD HAVE TURNED AND
ACTUALLY ENGAGE THE SUSPECT.
IF THEY GET INTO AN ALTERCATION,
THAT'S FINE.
IF THEY HAVE TO USE THEIR TASER,
IF THEY HAVE TO USE FORCE OTHER
THAN THAT, THAT'S FINE BECAUSE
THE NEXT OFFICER THAT GOES IN
THAT NEIGHBORHOOD, MAYBE HE'LL
GET A BUCKET OF PAINT.
MAYBE A BUCKET OF BLEACH.
MAYBE EVEN SOME ACID.
THIS IS A JOB THAT IS TOUGH, AND
IF YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO ENGAGE
-- THIS WASN'T DECISION BY
SOMEBODY IN AN IVORY TOWER.
THIS WASN'T A CAPTAINS DECISION
OR POLICE COMMISSIONER.
THIS WAS THE TWO OFFICERS ON THE
STREET.
THEY WERE IN CHARGE OF THE
SITUATION, AND THEY DID NOTHING.
>> Laura: YEAH, IT'S GOT TO BE
INCREDIBLY DEMORALIZING FOR
POLICE OFFICERS AND I KNOW
TALKING TO A NUMBER OF THEM OVER
THE LAST ONE FOR HOURS, SINCE WE
WERE THE FIRST TO PUT THIS VIDEO
ON NATIONAL TV, THEY ARE
INFURIATED ACROSS A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES.
LATE TONIGHT, NYPD RELEASED
PICTURES OF THREE OF THE
SUSPECTS IN THESE WATER ATTACKS.
ALSO NYPD IS NOTIFYING OFFICERS
ABOUT THE CHARGES THAT CAN BE
BROUGHT AGAINST THESE THUGS, SO
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT FORMER NYPD
COMMISSIONER BURNING CHARACTER
TOLD US LAST NIGHT.
WATCH.
>> OBSTRUCTION, DISORDERLY
CONDUCT, HARASSMENT, NUMBER OF
OTHER CHARGES BUT THEY WON'T BE
CHARGED BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
MIRROR IN NEW YORK CITY --
>> Laura: HE SENT DISGRACE.
WHAT CHANCE DO THEY HAVE OF
CATCHING AND CHARGING THESE GUYS
AND DO YOU AGREE WITH
MARK FUHRMAN'S ANALYSIS THAT IS
TETHYS THIS JOB IS, IF THE
OFFICERS DON'T WANT TO ENGAGE ON
THE SCENE, THEY SHOULD NO LONGER
BE POLICE OFFICERS AND GO INTO A
DIFFERENT LINE OF WORK.
GOD BLESS THEM.
>> THERE'S A PARTIAL TRUTH TO
WHAT MARK IS EXCITING BUT MARK
COMES FROM A DIFFERENT TIME.
BACK WHEN POLICE WERE SUPPORTED
AND THERE WERE NO CAMERAS THAT
WERE BEING STUCK IN EVERY
STASIS.
WHEN A HIGHLIGHT THE PANTALEO
EFFECT, THE OFFICERS ENFORCING
MINOR CRIMES OF LOOSE
CIGARETTES, WHERE'S THE BACKING?
IT'S EASY FOR US TO SAY WHAT
OFFICERS SHOULD DO BUT WE ARE
NOT THE ONES WHERE THERE WHEN IT
HAPPENS AND WE ARE THE ONES
GETTING INDICTED BECAUSE OF
PUBLIC OUTCRY OVER NONSENSE.
IT'S EASY TO BE OPINIONATED FROM
ONE SIDE BUT MARK AND I BOTH
COME FROM DIFFERENT TIME
PERIODS, AND I'M STILL THERE AND
I SEE WHAT'S OCCURRING IN
POLICING TODAY.
>> Laura: MARK, RESPOND.
>> WELL, I MEAN, THAT'S ALL WELL
AND GOOD BUT I CAN REMEMBER MANY
TIMES THAT I WASN'T SUPPORTED BY
THE CHIEF OF POLICE ON DOWN
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY ENGAGE
MULTIPLE PEOPLE THAT WERE TRYING
TO ASSAULT US, ROCKS, BOTTLES,
GUNSHOTS.
WE STILL ENGAGED.
WE CALLED FOR ASSISTANCE, AND
YES, IT GOT UGLY.
BUT YOU DIDN'T LOSE YOUR GROUND,
NUGENT WALK AWAY WITH YOUR TAIL
BETWEEN YOUR LEGS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO DO THAT, GIVE
UP THE STREETS.
THE NEXT TIME SOMEBODY --
>> WE ARE NOW PROMOTING VIDEOS
OF BASICALLY KARAOKE SINGING
CONTEST.
WE'VE GONE FROM ENFORCEMENT,
WE'VE GONE FROM A PARAMILITARY
ORGANIZATION TO FEEL GOOD AND WE
SPEND ENERGY AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON CREATING A FEEL-GOOD
TO THE POINT WHERE OFFICERS ARE
GETTING INDICTED FOR NONSENSE
AND ARE NOT GETTING THE BACKING
OF THE NYPD.
>> Laura: HOLD ON A SECOND.
HOLD ON.
I WANT TO PUT THIS FULL-SCREEN
UP.
LOOK AT WHAT THIS CURRENT
ATMOSPHERE HAS DONE TO
RECRUITMENT OF POLICE OFFICERS.
CHECK IT OUT.
NYPD RECRUITMENT IS DOWN, DOWN,
DOWN.
ONLY 330 PEOPLE AS
OF APRIL 2019.
LOOK AT WHERE IT WAS IN JULY OF
2017.
524.
JANUARY 2010, THEY DID PRETTY
WELL BUT IT DOESN'T LOOK SO GOOD
RIGHT NOW, MARK.
WHAT'S NEXT FOR RECRUITMENT?
THEY CAN HIRE POLICE OFFICERS IN
PLACES LIKE NEW ORLEANS THE LAST
TIME I CHECKED.
OTHER PLACES BECOME A TRICKLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, SAME THING.
>> THERE CERTAIN PLACES WHERE
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE AT
THE HIGH STANDARDS.
LOS ANGELES, NEW YORK, IT SHOULD
BE A FEW OTHER CITIES.
THE HEART OF THE MATTER IS
LEADERSHIP.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A GOOD LEADER,
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY THINK
LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD BE.
A GOOD LEADER WILL GIVE THEM THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY NEED.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO ENGAGE WITH
BAD ACTORS ON THE STREET, YOU
NEED TO ENGAGE.
IF YOU DON'T, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
WORRY ABOUT AN OFFICER GETTING
INDICTED.
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO GET KILLED.
SUSPECTS ARE GOING TO GET
KILLED, AND OFFICERS ARE GOING
TO GET KILLED.
THIS IS JUST ONE STEP.
THE NEXT ONE WILL BE MORE THAN
WATER.
BECAUSE THEY GOT AWAY WITH IT.
>> Laura: THE DISRESPECT OF
THE POLICE AND FOR EACH OTHER, I
MEAN, IT IS ALL RIDICULOUS AT